[Music]
this morning researchers at the
University of california-davis
continue its three-day coffee sensory
summit the university wants to be a
worldwide epicenter of coffee research
just as climate change threatens the
multi-billion dollar industry Purdue
researchers have reported that
three-quarters of the farmers in
Columbia say droughts have gotten longer
61% say the land is eroding and nearly
the same number see an increase in crop
disease five years ago a scientific
journal warned forward-looking research
on adaption is therefore in high demand
across the entire supply chain that
research is now being done in Davis and
Beyond in both conventional and novel
ways the main goal today is to
illustrate the principle of conservation
of mass bill Wriston Hart isn't your
average chemical engineering professor
for today we're gonna be doing a whole
bunch of brews and the mr. coffee here's
the same amount of water every time okay
but then systematically vary the mass of
the coffee grounds in his introduction
to chemical engineering class the design
of coffee students get to discover the
science inside a cup of joe and then
Part B this is real exciting we get to
do our first roast are you guys excited
about that okay
ristin part started the class in 2013 as
a freshman seminar the idea came to him
during what else a coffee break with a
colleague we were drinking coffee one
day thinking about how to improve our
engineering labs and she suggested that
idea why don't we have our students take
apart a mr. coffee drip brew and I
thought oh my gosh why don't we make a
whole class about coffee
the class that started with just 18
students is now attended by two thousand
a year its popularity was highlighted a
few years back in a campus poll one of
their questions was what is the best
general education class and number one
was the design of coffee
number two is introduction to human
sexuality and number three was
introduction to beer brewing and so now
we like to say that at UC Davis coffee
is better than beer and sex it's a good
selling point for a lot of people it is
what we didn't anticipate was how much
interest there was from the industry and
they came to us and said hey you know we
need research there are a lot of
unanswered questions about coffee at
Coffee phases a lot of issues and we
would love to partner with somebody in
academia UC Davis is well known for its
agricultural research in fields like
beer brewing and viticulture or wine
growing they actually have a vineyard
right on campus and so one of our big
goals is to make UC Davis an
international location of excellence to
create an academic talent pipeline to
support the coffee industry they've
already built a coffee center with a
prototype pilot roastery run by the
former head roaster at Blue Bottle
coffee a brewing and espresso laboratory
and a dedicated sensory lab in all there
are about 35 professors teaching courses
on everything from food science to
global social change in coffee cultures
1500 to present why do we need somebody
who knows how to do these things
anything that helps the confidence tree
produce better cups of coffee of higher
quality to increase demand helps not
only people here in the United States
but also there's a tremendous number of
people around the world who live in
developing countries whose livelihood
depends on coffee and so there's about a
hundred million people who make a living
by picking coffee one of the existential
threats to their livelihoods and our
cups of coffee is climate change it's a
huge concern there are lots of
discussions right now about whether
we'll have coffee in 30 years three
years ago UC Davis had a breakthrough
that could have a profound impact on
coffees survival when one Medrano and
Allen Van dines became the first
geneticists to create a reference genome
for a coffee bean for the
a person what does that mean when you
say there's no genome - right there was
no reference you know so there's no book
that tells me what is the sequence and
the genes in the copy genome okay and
that was very surprising to me because
being an industry that is 20 billion
dollar industry 2.4 million cups of
coffee every year and there's no genome
sequence when most crops have a sequence
why do we need the genomes for plants
like this it's a tool in plant breeding
it's a second most traded commodity in
the world but nobody's looking at it at
the plant level the pair honed in on C
Arabica the beam behind 70 percent of
worldwide consumption coffee has grown
almost exclusively outside of the United
States but ban dines a Medrano picked a
Geisha variety grown in Goleta
California from the good land organics
farm we first featured nearly three
years ago also basically you take
beliefs of coffee of a coffee plant
right and this leaf so coffee plants are
macerated and you extract DNA from the
cells inside the leaves ok and then you
create a collection of DNA fragments
well we ended up putting together was
1.2 billion base pairs so pieces of DNA
they're not a hundred percent in order
but they're in a very good shape the
goal is to breed a plant that can grow
at higher altitudes and fight diseases
like rust we say this all the time but
the coffee bean is it's magical outside
of academia the Seattle start up at Tomo
Coffee is taking the exact opposite
approach to coffee research food
scientists jarett's stop forth and his
co-founder and eke like want to make
coffee without the bean they call it
molecular coffee we talked about how
when he told me he wanted a hack coffee
that it blew my mind but it really did
it always gets everyone just imagining
like what is that how does that work
ship it over to Seattle Otomo mixes
plant-based agricultural byproducts and
caffeine that when combined mimics
actual coffee down to the aroma and
flavor the company which launched last
February on Kickstarter has raised 2.5
million dollars in venture capital we
joke around that this is
the $10,000 a cup of coffee right now
but as we scale our production will see
our costs drop pretty dramatically in
which we should be able to make coffee
that is great tasting that is actually
cheaper to produce than coffee today at
Omo plans to roll out its cold brew
coffee later this year as it waits for
patent approval while UC Davis has made
the Arabica genome publicly available to
anyone why not make money off of it the
basic knowledge of the reference genome
it's really an opportunity for many
scientists for many people in different
parts of the world to benefit and
produce great coffees from it and that's
the ingenuity this is pre competitive
research is a good way of looking at it
we're a public institution and the idea
is let's raise the bar for everybody
Medrano who's now retired from the
university is a co-founder of fringe
coffee with jay [ __ ] of good land
organics this is our greenhouse this
plant right here is one that's education
yeah this is exactly the one that was
sequence this is a unique hybrid you
know that is resistant to frost this
coffee has 40% less caffeine the midday
coffee again not too tired
it has a very floral bay exquisite
flavor when the aroma is fantastic I
would say this is an all-day drinking
coffee it's delicious really delicious
interesting yeah I mean it's the bottom
line is can we make a stronger coffee
bean so that it can survive some of the
climate change or can we find other
plant-based things that we can combine
so that we can have coffee and that's
what both these places are doing because
this is a real issue because UC Davis
believes they've scientifically
established that coffee is better than
beer and sex
apparently capice I would like to taste
for myself so I'm wondering the one
without the one without the actual beans
yes I'll work on that they're working to
get their cold brew released out to the
public right right waiting for some
happy
well we're up first